hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu
and this here is my friend biski say
hello to the fans biscay
hello now bisco tell us a bit about
yourself well
i look young my age but i have super
hunter powers and i'm more powerful than
any of the other kid characters on the
sorry we're going to have to stop you
there for a moment
uh hiskey please stop trying to sneak on
to set
it's biscay's segment no sookie please
no schwing you would you said you
wouldn't do this
let's just move on with the segment
episode 64.
there's a lot to discuss about the
overall balance of this episode and we
got a clear definition between the
storylines today but can
i start by saying how wonderful it is to
see gon
and quiloar learning together the
relationship between them is developing
into that of teammates
before they were two kids sort of
traveling together now they're teammates
flowing together and the training is
bringing their ability together really
well we've seen their special skills a
lot in the show but having biscuit note
is it bisky or biscuit
biscuit note that kilauea's strength is
in his analysis and physical strength
while gonz is in concentration and
recovery
is a great callback to the transmuter
enhancer aspect of them
kilowatt's analysis and physical
strength in the dark a few episodes back
meant that he could dislocate his
fingers and free himself picking up the
plan leorio was
laying down meanwhile gohan's focus
leads him to ask the right questions and
get himself back on track
despite not being the smartest cookie in
the tin it's incredible to see
and i love the detail that's gone into
thinking through how
that story is told and interpreted and
how it's allowed to be interpreted by
the audience before it's said that biski
is
enjoying the training process is also
evident she's a little nutty but
and i like that she finally fixed her
hairstyle i've been watching it this
whole time thinking okay sure but
someone who cares
so much about protecting their hands
with white gloves would do something
about that whether they're focused on it
or not like i would do something that
gets heavy like you get un you get
lopsided like
it it but it's done and i'm glad okay so
we got an episode of extreme learning
today on a day when
i was not really prepared for extreme
learning remember how last week we
i was discussing the weirdness involved
in panting the story and deciding to
tell people everything about a given
topic
well today we learned about an entire
system of magical combat
now i understand that as a kid i would
have hung on this i think
i'd have been in my lounge room intently
taking all the positions to release my
korrenten
and it should the idea that tokashi's
thought through this world
so much the story is tied into us
knowing and understanding how
and why we're doing what we're doing is
really admirable i'm sure you can hear a
big butt putin around there because here
it comes
but on several occasions i've mentioned
my concerns with kids
that age watching this show i don't
actually know because i haven't looked
at it what recommended age for the manga
and anime actually are
i'm also not trying to underestimate the
amount that kids can perceive and deduce
about the world i've had kids tell me
the most incredibly perceptive things
about politics
and the state of the world so it's not
that at all it's the combination of the
characters involved
the world the detail given and the
violence the problem with anything
animated is
unfortunately that it's animated bright
colors are wonderful and they draw the
eye and they get everyone interested at
first glance before we really connect
with things
we love bright colors but for example
bright colors don't mean
safety and they don't mean something's
for child consumption
as an eight-year-old i would have been
diving across the lounge room and
flipping into chairs in amazement that
movement so slow as biscuits could have
such an intense reaction on a character
i know to be extremely powerful
adult waifu thinks that's amazing too
and if i had a couch
in the room where i watch these episodes
i probably would be flipping onto the
couch anyway
i love that it happened but i don't know
that eight-year-old me would have taken
in that amount of detail
from the rest of the episode and i don't
know that
year old me needs it i guess what i'm
trying to say is that i think there may
have been a better way to tell this
particular chunk of story there is so
much information coming at me when what
i want is the story moving forward
do i need to know the entire history of
rock paper scissors i know it's
fascinating and it genuinely is
fascinating but still do i need that
much detail on top of
everything and i'm just one person and i
totally get that but just
when i start to get a handle on exactly
what ten
you and the others are
all of a sudden there's more to link
into it's like i'm being sent to a power
kid school and while i'm loving the
story of how they come of age and grow
strong and achieve their ambitions and
learn to sync up even with their
separate skill sets i'm
and i don't even want to say
uninterested i just don't know if the
information is organized in a way that
makes it easy for me to understand and
remember week to week which
if you recall is how i watch these i
watch two episodes a week which is still
more than someone who watched it when it
aired
got and less than someone binging arcs
for a little more context as to why i do
it this way i basically work more than
full time hours i literally don't have
the time to binge anything and i spend a
lot of my week thinking about other
things that the show still engages me is
simply incredible because
i'm really hard to keep engaged in
things long term and i know that that
annoys liam
i love watching anime when i get time
and right now that time is hunter hunter
if you need higher praise for the show
than that i really can't give it to you
and the fact that there is actually
enough in it for me to wax lyrical or
get mad at it every week for a fair
chunk of time tells you something about
that too
i do not dislike this show i just kind
of
need concepts moved around a bit or for
it not to feel like a textbook is being
read at me
because i start to drift anyway jumping
to the end of the episode
let's briefly talk about the culture of
the bomber please because that's
what it is isn't it right they joined
the cult and now they've been tagged
with culti ickiness and
they need to deal with that the places
they'd all been touched
to get bombs placed on them some of them
on their heads and faces
i'm sorry no one is allowed to touch my
head like that and say weird words
especially bomber
what even makes you think that's okay
rip poo hat i guess
tried to be clever all the way to the
end failed as expected
it's such a cat and mouse game that's
being played on that side of the table
i'm still not sure where this arc is
going but it seems as though there are
going to be a number of
weird people trying to get hold of
whatever gone and kilwa have
gone and killed meanwhile have become
stronger so it seems very much as though
they're going to have another haha
they're kids
wait no kids can't do this situation i
simply can't wait
i mean i really can this trope is
becoming a trope now
and so i'm hoping that's not where it
goes but let's see oh
also are the phantom troop just going to
start killing people from outside the
game
if anything i want more of that story
tell me more about what's going on there
and let's see what happens next episode
65. today i learned that volleyball can
be really dangerous
like more dangerous than that volleyball
anime that i was
watching for a little bit that i need to
get i'll get back to it
having come in from the outside
apparently you can't do what the phantom
troop tried to do and cheat your way in
which honestly i'm glad about
i guess someone has to protect the items
they have but also
have they just lined all the bodies of
those in the game out on this rocky
island
and how is this dangerous volleyballer
just sitting around
if gone goes and talks to him will he
learn where his father is is is he
the last person that you know you see in
the game is he like the the end boss
will the end boss tell him where his dad
is i have so many questions that won't
be answered because they decided to
actually play by the rules dammit troop
how am i supposed to learn meta
mechanics of this strange world if
you're gonna go in through the front
door and try to beat it that's unfair
also actually to be clear these
pre-episode and mini interludes are
exactly the storytelling i want to teach
me about how the world works rather than
oh no please help me why is there so
much text on the screen and how am i
supposed to know what this card does
without pausing every time to read it
that would have seriously stressed me
out as a kid young adult i mean seeing
the card stresses me out now
they don't discuss what the card can do
more than
look they do discuss what the card can
do but they don't give you enough
information about what the card can do
for you to
then not need to pause the episode they
just put the text up and use it a moment
later
i are stressed i'm sorry this episode so
far has been focused on the overall
aesthetic of the series but it's
something that's been building up for
some time to this point so i just needed
to be done with it
it's interesting seeing biski being
supportive verbally but thinking about
how childish gone is quietly
i don't know that they've had someone
like this before who has the passion of
a teacher but the sass of a protagonist
i don't know how to explain it i like it
though it brings me back to the
differences between biski and hiskey
really
she wants him to be all he can be as
does his hoka are they working together
to bring the perfect combatant to life
has he been
practicing his ten anywhere else she's
been watching him the whole time and
he's been sleeping with rocks over his
head
i suppose they've been going for months
at this point what are the others doing
while this is going on
it's such a beautiful thing to see kilwa
meeting the random were people gone met
in the beginning
for them to remember him and for the
exam to be starting again i take back
what i said a few episodes ago i'm kind
of excited to see as long as it's sped
up the process of the hunter exam does
that mean we're going to see
oh um that guy who did the thing with
the
zephyr that's his name
see i remember names does that mean
we'll see zephiel and hang on the um the
the dude who messed people up what's his
name
bing bong uh poopy mcdrinky pants no you
know who i mean i can't remember his
name right now oh
look i remember some names i don't
remember one name shush he ended up
getting tied up near the end of the exam
it was great that guy anyway gone's
learning how to scissor paper rocks
strongman style and there was something
great about seeing the art of this
episode develop because we're starting
to see
in action frames gone's musculature
develop and i don't think that's a
mistake i think it's a great piece of
detail
despite being kids there's only so much
you can work your aura
only so many mountains you can dig
through only so many punches you can
throw
before even as a kid your muscles begin
to pop or you don't look so lean and
wiry
you can tell time is passing because
even if they don't look older
their bodies are changing and i can't
say how much i appreciate that
dudebra that came to warn them got a
snuggly caterpillar creature friend
he didn't really come to warn them
expecting much though
we can add him to the underestimates
physically unimposing children pyle
which seems to encompass everyone except
hisoka
the phantom troop wing okay it seems to
encompass everyone we could describe as
a main character so i won't list them
all
now that we've been introduced to the
real villain of this arc let's
get into it i'm kind of excited for gone
to have to deal with someone who's just
flat out evil
there's no recourse for that guy he's
simply evil not even
mentally ill that's not mentally ill he
knows exactly what he's doing and could
choose not to do that thing
hisoka has motivations and doesn't do
things just to be mean he has problems
but he's not plain evil
gone and killed are many psychopaths but
they have passions and hopes and dreams
and to a certain extent i feel like
they're trying to be better than they
are but don't know how
that guy evil until we're given some
intense backstory but even then
evil and on that evil evil evil note
that's it from me
if you enjoyed this and want to see or
hear more click on this thing
this thing and this thing there's also a
discord and another thing over here
and oh oh don't forget thumbs up thumbs
down
there are thumbs have thumbs all thumbs
for you and i'll see you next time